do here is find a series of only moves
if he has to find good moves if you
force him to play well that will only
help niemann just give him a lot of
choice on every turn that's normally a
good strategy against someone who's
in bad form on tilt
well a sensible opening move from magnus
cross nothing strange about that not yet
so it's the sicilian defense neiman
choosing the sicilian that already shows
ambitious uh intentions i'm slightly
surprised i thought maybe niemann
would try to play something solid just
try to survive this first game but the
sicilian we m we've also got to say here
magnus goes very well with both colors
in this opening
and uh what will magnus do he brings his
bishop out no open sicilian today um the
rossolimo variation with white's bishop
potentially capturing this black knight
and uh ruining the black pawn structure
magnus very famous for playing this
setup himself as black interesting
psychology do you think here guys
playing one of magnus's favorite
openings against him maybe
yeah i mean this as you say was famously
played in the world championships uh
when magnus carson was normally black
against fabiano caruana
they battled him this many times um
i don't know what he's thinking is but i
was just thinking who would win a boxing
match between the two it was just going
from my head like you know which one of
them would i take in a boxing match but
we won't go there ready
don't they they're both you know young
fit and quite sturdy characters so it
would be an interesting uh interesting
chess boxing fight that one um but this
is all normal stuff david and maybe i'll
let you go through the moves and yeah as
as we see them develop yeah this is
still very normal stuff uh we have seen
a bishop for night trade and a very
flashy night check here from magnus
carlsen um this
okay we saw it just flash there quickly
but he did temporarily sacrifice a
knight it was kind of a pseudo-sacrifice
so it wasn't really giving up a piece
but it has forced the black king to move
so if you notice the black king it has
lost castling rights and
neiman's stretching there
it looks a little bit bizarre i mean i
think that's a good sign actually it's
like a power pose to say hey
i'm here i'm dominant i am the alpha
male
i i don't know why i said that
i think that's what it is it's body
language and
you can see just the speed he's playing
he's trying to play quicker than magnus
in a way okay slow down a little bit but
there there's a little bit of an ego
thing maybe going on here but they're
just
getting their theory out there quickly
yeah i've got to say as well uh when i
played at the olympiad recently every
morning when i woke up first thing i do
stretch power pose in bed before waking
up just convince yourself i did read
somewhere that it's uh it's a way of
tricking yourself into thinking that you
are it obviously worked
there's a good psychology behind that
just to reinforce and there we see a
porn move from magnus um but it's to do
with the fact that you know often when
you're playing chess you know you're
problem solving that activates like
other kind of things like over anxiety
and worry
and instead if you're kind of like do
these power poses have mantras it builds
up this protection against this
yeah and the position is evolving
slightly so black has lost the right to
castle black also has a set of double
pawns on the c file but uh black is
relatively active got a lot of control
over the center and um this is
interesting to me because i remember
studying this exact position and magnus
and his seconds have a lot of experience
here i remember nils grindelius a
swedish player had explored this type of
position with white
some very strong grandmasters this last
night move for black maybe not the most
critical if i remember correctly black
hat did have the option
to be a bit greedy a bit more ambitious
but hans clearly just wants to grip and
survive
this opening and just to show one or two
points before we talk about more about
body language and the psychology here
but
if we just retreat if we kind of
roll back just three or four moves
magnus here with white in a very
standard position did jump in with a
night check and uh this does look like a
sacrifice this check but if the knight
is captured by the black pawn then this
is a discover check discovered attack
against the black king and when the king
moves or the check is blocked white will
regain the peace with interest by
capturing this bishop so uh this check
was actually refused likewise taking
with the bishop would not be good only
opens up the white rook and uh instead
this check meant the black king had to
move and although white lost to tempe
lost two moves with this knight and the
fact that the black king here uh kind of
sits in the way of its own pieces
uncastled that will be a factor long
term and hans brought his bishop out
creating a pin white pushed a pawn
forward and if i remember correctly from
studying this position maybe six months
or a year ago black's critical move is
to actually take this pawn uh utilizing
the fact that the white knight cannot
recapture the white knight is pinned
arterial and there's a very long
variation here that does lead to what i
thought was an equal position
and i'm slightly surprised that hans
didn't go for this
if you want to kind of calculate deeply
work on these openings with computers
then i think you would be able to play
this move with relative confidence
and uh the variation continues white i
think it pushes forward upon and we get
a position where white isn't pawn down
but will regain it uh due to the fact
that black king is weak the black bishop
is a bit loose but uh instead han's just
putting his knight on this square and
magnus may be surprised just thinking
for the first time
in the game
yeah what do we think about this
decision by hands not kind of forcing
the issue not being greedy grabbing a
pawn instead just parking his night on a
nice outpost and saying
okay you prove it magnus well it
actually has been played before and uh i
mean it's interesting you mentioned
niels grandelius because of course he
worked with magnus but i'm checking the
database and it says that niels
grandelius actually beat nihal sarin you
know and one of india's promising
talents
in this opening with the white pieces
and uh also arkady naidic a very strong
german grandmaster
yeah
changes a lot it has changed and uh he
also beat another very strong grand
master of roganovic and just taking a
look i can see that there are like four
victories for white
and uh about seven draws okay so no
victories for black in this position and
what was white's most common move
because to me it's not 100 clear how to
solve this
uh solve this pin situation this this
move that magnus has just played so he
plays the most common and maybe most
successful move and just challenging
this strong black knight this night is
after all a very strong piece holding
everything together for black so it
makes sense to trade it off
and uh i'm assuming that we'll see an
exchange here
and maybe the black queen
coming into the center
something along these lines maybe black
will try and kick this bishop out of his
half of the board either way it's a very
rich position a lot of complexities here
and
i think black's big problem is that his
king is not on a good
square it seems that if if all the
active pieces get swapped off so the
ones you've highlighted there david
white should just be better because the
king position uh i mean it's not just
the black king position but it's a rook
in the corner
you're playing a rook down
and obviously at the moment black only
two black active pieces the knight and
the bishop so i i like magnus's moves
he's trying to get rid of one of them
just very logical and if you can somehow
swap the bishop off then
you're going to leave black with some
horrendous pieces so um it seems
positionally quite dangerous for black
at the moment
um you know how do you got to try to
keep some tension here if you don't
you're just worse
so how do you keep how do you keep the
tension is there any way you can do that
here yeah i don't see it you're right
simon also this bishop um from when i
was studying these types of positions
this bishop is often just caught kind of
staring at a pawn just uh just a very
bad piece whereas white's kind of
counterpart dark square bishop has
decent potential yeah um you're right
simon no no way that i see to keep the
tension for example if the black knight
wants to avoid this exchange and jumps
into the center then white can just
challenge okay he has taken but white
can challenge this pinning bishop and
we'll just see a bunch of exchanges
leaving black with his
poor pieces yeah
and uh
okay yeah so the the the players have
actually chosen something different i
just wanted to highlight one move that
was played in this particular position
in the game that i referenced between
niels grandelius and new house aaron uh
white actually
there's you know there's some
uncomfortable pressure
along the night and to meet that white
simply just played the rook all the way
to the e4 square attacking the bishop
which i thought was quite a nice move
yeah i remember this game uh i think it
was in vaikansei
sigaman oh siegeman ah yeah one of these
close tournaments and uh nils played a
really nice game there and there were
actually some really nice checkmating
patterns later in that game to do with
the black king
being caught on this square some back
rank checkmating ideas and uh this did
involve a pawn sacrifice if i remember
correctly and uh black can still grab
this pawn but it's much more dangerous
now that the white pieces are kind of
pouring forward black's king is not a
happy bunny at all i mean magnus
like 99 percent must be aware of that
game
um not just because nils is the second
but he's just got phenomenal memory
he he knows all the the games and the
variation he plays so you must be aware
of that i i would assume and i mean with
that rook move david i mean what what
happens i mean just
for me i'm just wondering what happens
the bishop drops back
uh something like this would would seem
like logical to me yeah and
see if white can make progress i suppose
even if you just drop the bishop back
the rook back one square it's a better
square i don't know but it's
yeah yeah i mean maybe this is a
safer path for black at least now with
the two bishops you have some long-term
hopes at least you can kind of plug the
light squares with uh this bishop
but uh yeah long term it's quite likely
black will kind of get kicked back at
some point with a knight or wow you
might see this coming yeah he's played
it so yeah current position is this one
hitting the bishop and
it does look like the safest way is to
retreat the bishop unless you've got
something specific in mind here and i
think the speed of hans's next move will
tell us a lot either he's prepared this
deeply and found an improvement on that
game we mentioned and uh he's found a
way for black to survive maybe by
dropping the bishop back or he might be
facing big big trouble taking the knight
looks suicidal to me
i mean i i don't know if that's what
nihal played but it looks really
dangerous to get rid of your only active
piece and
white's pieces are so well positioned
the rook the queen the bishop the other
rook coming over uh black's king badly
placed black's rooks badly played this
looks just visually terrible for black
even if you win a pawn uh so what it
doesn't make any difference here so yeah
the right simon you don't even have to
calculate you just see the black king
stuck and yeah you play this position
with white totally and i also just want
to point out that if you look at the
clock times as well if you were to
compare them you'd see that magnus just
over 11 minutes
while hands is just over seven minutes
which suggests to me he doesn't quite
know
this particular line and so he has
retreated the bishop now one kind of
very professional way is to repeat the
position twice just to dangle that draw
and then uh just diverge
and uh expecting magnus to go back where
he came from yes
yes just tempt hands to try and uh go
for the draw for the draw petition and
to say no it just seems to be the trendy
way to do it you know i saw wesley so do
it numerous times on every occasion we
actually saw um in the ftx someone kept
doing it who was it
way he was just like phenomenal
every single time he got a chance he
loved doing it so yeah yeah at the
olympiad in round one um i i played a
game against cyprus and afterwards i
talked to the english number one michael
adams and he was like it's a miracle
that wasn't a three-fold repetition but
i was like don't worry i was repeating
twice every time just to
just to tease my opponent and torture
them
it doesn't make sense to kind of
especially when psychologically neiman
is so fragile right now yeah he's so
yeah i mean you can play on that maybe
yeah what happens if he plays rookie one
and then he says draw
over the top of the computer and neiman
says yes
and then he goes no he's only joking
he says i haven't offered a draw on the
computer and then he saw haha
what happens then so
we'd see that in the adult chest
fight in the arena
boxing fight
we did have a move from
magnus nothing dramatic happening no
rather than retreat the white rook he's
just attacking the black queen first and
wherever the black queen goes next we'll
see the white rook commit and retreat
you did mention it david hans being a
little bit fragile a tilt yesterday
we're wondering will he make a comeback
today or will the tilt continue we're
going to go down to savada in miami
being close to the players interviewing
them and svaria today we heard some
short answers from hans yesterday in
your interviews very short answers how
do you read hansa's mentality right now
it's quite the difference from how he
started out in this tournament because
he was one of the more vocal players i
mean i think he was close to world
domination in the interview we did prior
to the tournament
now he's a little bit more unsure but
i asked him to join me today for for
uh some takes and such prior to starting
but he was just a play no that was not
an ability and it's a bit of a different
personality so i'm i am a little bit
worried about hans and how he manages to
reset for this game against magnus
and yeah you mentioned also an interview
before the whole tournament started what
did he say to you in that interview
before the ftx crypto cup
that was quite interesting because hans
is a he's a fascinating player and he's
a fascinating person and he's extremely
sociable he's extremely
friendly he i mean he's a character
unlike anything we've seen in chess but
he has such extreme faith in his own
abilities i mean this is a guy who's
increased his rating during the pandemic
when everyone else has been pretty much
sitting silent but he's also a player
who may not have this live experience
that so many of the other players do so
it's an unknown territory for him and i
think he still has a little bit of
maturing to do when it comes to how he
handles the losses and how he actually
handles the slaps in the face that will
come when you face the top players in
the world
absolutely very interesting but uh
talking in the interview was right
before the tournament about world
domination he really does seem like a
confident guy and he does that's why he
says have these slaps in his face from
time to time
and it was an interesting point uh
before the pandemic in 2020 uh he was
rated about 2400 to 24.50 and now he's
gained over 200 points um in less than
two years so i mean he's on a massive
upward
trajectory and uh yeah sometimes when
you get your first setback or when you
get a series of setbacks it's just so
hard to recover you need a few months to
kind of consolidate that gain that
you've made just even plateauing even
keeping your rating is a big gain but i
think just because he's in this mindset
of okay i can do anything um i think
that's why he's kind of reacting as he
is
right now but he's given interviews in
the past he said he's the most talented
american player since fischer he
definitely doesn't lack for self-belief
and uh
more talented than hikaru
that's what he reckons his words not
mine
fabiano
the list could go on
wow that's a big statement that is so so
he just needs to back it up now but uh i
think no matter how this match goes
today he'll just want to post a good
performance in this tournament yeah he
shouldn't be aiming to win it i mean
nobody comes in um in their big
breakthrough year and suddenly beats the
world champion beats everyone all the
top players in a row you just need to
kind of
give yourself a little bit of confidence
some self-belief and uh go from there
yeah
it was really interesting actually when
it comes to self-belief and what kind of
things you should be aiming for because
we did some work with the england team
performance coach and he was saying to
us you know
you should never have aims
that are results-based because you can't
ever control the outcome
so if he goes in there it's like okay
i'm going to play good exciting chess
this is my aim he can control that he
can control his attitude he cannot
control whether he will win
so to speak because you know that's
actually dependent on magnus as well
yeah even if you play a perfect game if
your opponent plays perfectly as well
it's just going to be a draw so
that's really interesting you've just
got to feel like you're playing well and
um yeah he just needs to make himself or
at least trick himself into thinking
he's in the flow again and playing well
and it's not to do with external factors
like tech issues it's not to do with the
opponent it's just him uh just focus on
his own kind of uh his own game right
now but i do like what he's been doing
hans over the last few moves black does
still have the bishop here you're right
simon don't trade off your bishops uh in
this type of position and he's also
blocked white's pawn in the centre of
the board with the black queen queens
aren't great blockades but for now it
looks pretty sturdy this setup i think
he's playing very well at the moment i
mean uh i like what he's done on the
king side as well um he's he's moved
those pawns so he's actually made
white's bishop a little bit bad
um and and those pawns the g h pawns
have potential
to to run up the board and actually
attack the white king at some point you
could use them very proactively and uh
uh he's playing he's playing very well
at the moment at this moment in time so
he he's uh you know if he keeps this up
he's you know
gonna really challenge magnus actually i
think yeah i'm not sure this is a magnus
type of position because magnus wants to
invite all of his pieces into the game
he wants to get this rook working
somehow he wants to get his queen
to a better square but he has to deal
with ideas active ideas from his
opponent and okay just a calm little
pawn push here
is this a good idea giving the white
king some space long term maybe giving
the bishop a retreat square or is this
what we call a hook where black can
kind of use this pawn to open up lines
later towards the white king it's a bit
risky for magnus
what he's doing black still needs to get
this rook in the game but i mean if you
could somehow magically teleport the
black rook uh over over his own pieces
to this square team up against this
backward pawn suddenly black would just
be strategically winning and hans may be
trying to do that maybe trying to just
move his king across move his king out
the way connect the black rooks
i was going to ask the question because
uh you kind of highlighted something
that was going to bother me a little bit
you know white
has an okay position at the minute but
they do have some long-term weaknesses
and that is this backward pawn sitting
on d3 can't push forward
i mean how is magnus
good i mean is he good at dealing with
these types of
structural disadvantages he normally
hates accepting long-term structural
kind of deficiencies in his position um
he wants to solve them immediately for
example he would love to push this pawn
forward at some point trade it off but
it's just not possible right now
if he were to have done this on the last
move for example this pawn would drop
also on this d-file you are pinned so
you're not really achieving too much so
instead magnus he's trying to
push this pawn forward a bit of a
minority attack here it looks like these
are double pawns they're weaknesses but
actually they control a lot of important
central squares
so magnus is trying to deal with the
control of these pawns by pushing
forward trading off a flank pawn for a
slightly more central pawn
it does look slow though it looks very
slow yeah i mean
hans's idea is just move the king and
double rooks as you said
and he's playing this i mean i i thought
magnus could have
tried throwing the f pawn for us was a
bit more challenging but um okay he's
he's trying to maybe just improve his
pawn structure uh as you both said this
is more more magnus style but what would
you guys do now would you kind of trade
off here it does slightly improve
the white pawn structure i think i just
doubled up the white rook double row
yeah i agree with you just accept that
there's going to be some double pawns on
the board and continue with the plan be
consistent these double bonds i guess
they're only as weak as the pieces that
can attack them and white doesn't have
kind of the possibility to attack them
over the next two or three moves
so yeah suddenly this black rook which
we've been moaning and complaining about
suddenly it's ready to uh come and
target this massive weakness in the
white camp
black yeah i agree i should do
beforehand's position so he's doing that
right i mean maybe he's going to prove
he's the most talented player since uh
bobby fischer yeah
good stuff so far very impressive and
he's played exactly what we've just
showed we're heading in this direction
um he's even okay we do see this uh
recapture so he does have these double
pawns but i was gonna say he's uh just
gonna bring his rook across everything
connected for black now um the black
queen looking nice and pretty the black
bishop pointing down at this point the
only problem is that the black king is
slightly weak slightly loose long term
but
not an issue right now
maybe it's something in the air in the
miami arena today it's looking good for
also levon aronian with the black pieces
against young christophe duda on the bar
also over to a niche geary side with the
black pieces against pragnanda and we do
have
some stats for the players here in the
fdx crypto cup when it comes to
games with the black pieces so when we
look at the black score magnus carlsen
this season has performed the best 62
score with the black pieces hans niemann
he is in the bottom of that table only
scoring 34
with the black pieces but his tide's
turning now for hans the bar is going
over to his side yeah i guess in a
one-off game anything can happen but
yeah those that's they do surprise me
firstly that magnus is uh scoring so
high because 62 percent with black is
phenomenal magnus scores really
incredible with white as well so that's
uh that's uh yeah really high percentage
normally even 50 with black in a
tournament like this with all the
world's best players that is good but uh
yeah neiman needs to improve
and okay he's playing consistently
doubling up his rooks
yeah i'm just really loving his position
i'm surprised the evaluation bar's
actually in the middle because what is
white even doing i guess the other white
rook sat in the corner has to swing
across
there we go sit passively defending it's
backward d-pawn but all of white's
pieces are very stuck right now
maybe the computer just thinks it's
roughly level because black can't
improve maybe black's maximized his
pieces they're all on their kind of
perfect squares right now
how do you continue uh kind of creating
pressure
i mean imagine swinging the queen over
to keep hitting that weakness and
preparing preparing to advance your
kingside pawns is
very very natural way to play because at
the moment this is one weakness in the
middle that black's aiming everything at
i mean black's pawns in the long run on
the queen side are a bit ugly double
pawns means pain and you got the the
isolated pawn but the at the moment the
main problem is white's backwards pawn
which you've all pointed out so let's
just keep attacking that one swing the
queen over attack that prepare your
pawns to go forwards
and this this seems like you can well
you can keep improving his position at
the moment um which
is putting magnus on defensive he's
already had to play a defensive move
with his brook to defend that pawn and
it's not it's not nice defending
a weak pawn like this where you're going
very passive
not something that magnus would want to
do i'm sure before the game see yeah
definitely and uh
certainly not with the white pieces
against someone who he will really be
expecting to beat
and uh
how would he react here i mean does he
have to retreat his knight to a bad
square or can he maybe throw a pawn
forward try and
maybe solve his problems tactically
i think i think he has to do
aggressively to be honest yeah i mean
not moving the knight back looks just so
passive for then the h paul might come i
don't know i mean all the white's pieces
are just defending and that's not magnus
is it to to play like this but
i like you i like the idea that both you
suggested to move that pawn forwards
right i mean that that looks like at
least
something you could try i don't know if
it's any good but
i'm trying to work out i guess the idea
would be to jump forward with the white
knight it is a fork but the knight can
be removed and
i mean it's just one way traffic okay
hans has played the move we expect and
a position like this black is just a
pawn up yes we've managed to alleviate
some of the pressure but
i can still come back after this pawn
and magnus has played the very very ugly
night retreat that we were talking about
he just couldn't find another way
yeah the evaluation while hating this
for magnus all of the white pieces tied
down defending this one weakness and
when you go passive
it's never a good sign and white has
stepped back therefore black should step
forward that's the philosophy right
definitely
and it's a no-brainer hans neiman starts
advancing his pawns forward and what
magnus is just
his knight
back to its starting square
he's just lost two moves again earlier
he lost two moves with the night in the
opening as we showed there was a purpose
there but he's lost two moves again just
to force black to commit this pawn
i guess he's eyeing up a weakness on
this square but what a result this will
be fans wins with black after after
everything that's happened you know
it'll be that'd be amazing so uh yeah i
mean what should hans do here i mean it
looks really bad for white but we need a
breakthrough it's the idea if i guess if
black takes the pawn white can
take a pawn as well kind of thing for
example if the bishop captures this pawn
white can capture this pawn deflecting
away the black queen and now we would
just see a bunch of exchanges on this
square and probably just an equal end
game
i don't think this is what hans wants to
achieve he will want more out of the
position so he won't take this pawn
instead
what can he do
i mean i was tempted to i didn't really
didn't like the idea that you kind of
suggested which is like pushing the e
pawn one square forward just to jettison
his weight itself away maybe you could
stop that
and then and then perhaps activate the
dark square bishop just kind of forget
about your
your pawns
is is this
is there an h pawn to worry about um i
don't know it's coming yeah the h1 is
coming indeed and this pawn hits the
bishop the bishop forced back i like
this configuration because now this
bishop cuts off the only escape square
for the white king it's going to be all
sorts of background checkmates now
against the white king also white can't
now push the h pawn up which was
maybe a possible threat so all of these
pieces and now maybe you're playing your
banker and then you can move your dart
squad bishop somewhere and it just seems
like this your g pawn i love this
position
i really love these kind of positions
there he's played it
and he's got a big attack brewing as
well hasn't he against white's king with
all you need to do is push that g pawn
right yeah surely i mean look at the
white queen as well she's stuck on the
wrong side of the ball doing absolutely
nothing and therefore it makes complete
logical sense that an attack would come
against the white king soon do you see
that body language you see your hands
was like got his suit right
you know he's pulling his collar up he's
like yeah i'm the daddy
obviously a long way to go if he does
it's four games but i mean where would
you rate that comeback after what
happened yesterday and black pieces
against magnus cross unbelievable you
know i i i must admit you know seeing
him today at the
in in the interview with svara also
seeing his reaction yesterday also
seeing the reaction as well that he had
when he played the ftx road to miami and
the last two days of preliminaries
completely tilted yeah i thought it's a
no-brainer
you know magnus is just gonna
steamroller over him because you know
magnus is a shark you know he said it
himself you know
when he smells blood he will pounce
and instead what we're seeing here is
some fantastic chest by hands and this
is what we want to see him just play on
a move by move basis
and uh suddenly just like that i'm
loving everything that hans is doing and
i i hope he manages to achieve something
this is what i want to see i love the
underdog what can i say yeah yeah
everyone does yeah yeah but actually
talk about everyone does okay oh and
look at the bar yeah is this a blunder
by magnus carlsen it's maybe not a one
move blunder but it does not improve the
white position at all and it just gives
black a free move to continue that
attack that simon was mentioning the
attack will brew against the white king
eventually eventually black will prepare
a pawn break uh to push the black g pawn
forward and i don't really see what this
move does for magnus can you meet the
bishop
around to defend the h pawn um
yes he has
you could have gone the other way but
this this is just very nice
improving is this is like magnus chess
you know magnus would play like this is
black tie your opponent down improve
your pieces and then
break through but the thing with this
game he's got to do that breakthrough at
some point and that's when magnus will
get some counter chances i'd imagine you
know whenever he pulls the trigger on
the position but this this is it's a
scary plan anyway i mean firstly i've
got to point out look magnus has
retreated his knight again so over the
last what is it six seven moves magnus
has started with his knight on the
square he retreated it once brought it
back where it came from and retreated it
again so he's wasted three moves with
this knight alone and here we come the
breakthrough has happened yeah there's
consequences
we're expecting maybe the black queen to
capture on this square hitting the white
rook and uh for example
i mean i'm struggling to find a move for
white here if the knight goes back where
it came from uh the black bishop will
just move out the way the rook will
swing across and go for checkmate take
him to bishop also probably similar
and he's he is so easy to play for black
this position as well isn't it if you've
got the black pieces you line everything
up against white's king
and attack and it's really enjoyable
playing such a position so
you're 100 right simon i mean if you
showed us this game and said this is
casting against neiman you would assume
it's carlson with black it's carlson's
opening with black it's carson's style
with black
and uh yeah i mean neiman's just played
a perfect game so far we'll find out in
a minute hanging about it they got the
board the wrong way around
oh no it is actually carson
it crossed my mind but we did see hans
neiman's screen from the back so he does
have the black pieces from his side and
also his body language is quite clear
that yeah he's he's enjoying this game
at the moment
yeah and uh okay the pawn is kicking
away the bishop the bishop will just
take a step back where it came from most
likely and the attack continues this
bishop will move out the way maybe even
this diagonal hitting the white rook and
then the black rook will swing over
simple dress
and very good for black very effective i
have to say uh definitely looking
fantastic for black i mean i just wanted
to have a look what the computer says
whoa computers like minus three in black
it's really wow
i mean there's so many moves that
black's got i mean that bishop can now
come the other way the dark square
bishop
brooks i mean
there's hundreds of ideas
in the position the time well hans has
got enough time here as well can he keep
his call this is the thing he's
obviously that he's this emotional
player he knows that he's doing very
well here he knows he's got a great
chance of beating the world champion
with black this is a this is like the
real test now it's like can he finish
the game off can he keep his call which
you know i mean this is this is going to
be the big question now i think yeah
it's like a star striker in football
he's about to have a shot on goal it's
just keeping his calm he's just got to
keep doing what he's been doing so far
just not kind of getting too emotional
not getting impatient hasty he's just
got to pull the trigger at the right
time and as you mentioned there's simon
the bishop goes this way
looks pretty good yeah um i mean
i love the two bishops at the best of
times but these two black bishops just
look glorious
and easy plan next move you can almost
pre-move it black's rook in the center
just swinging across behind the black
queen beautiful position absolutely
beautiful position for black total
domination you have to do you can have
to play quite hard not to win this
um
as in the moves are quite easy to play
yeah i mean
i'm sure i i would manage very easily
but um sure magnus would defend against
most people in the world but uh yeah
it's true magnus is magnus yeah he'll
take any opportunity he gets the thing
is magnus cannot
you know do any active operations
whatsoever he just has to curl up in a
ball defense defend his king and just
hope for the best
just uh try and create problems and
survive on a move-by-move basis
what do you think hans is thinking now
he must be like you know
sit on your hands calm down i don't know
or like kill kill
i'm the daddy come on
we can have a look at him right now
um i mean he just looks like he's in
calculation mode and uh just as i said
that magnus has to go on the defensive
he goes on the counter attack i mean we
should mention as well magnus's big
weakness on the tour last season and
this season uh i say big weakness it's
relative it's his only weakness uh
magnus he does like to put his queen on
the wrong side of the board and uh
occasionally he gets checkmated if we
remember last season against dubov um
this this season against pragnanda
magnus has actually had the white queen
on this square and been checkmated on
the other side of the board while his
queen is uh kind of distracted so
i'm just getting flashbacks i think
actually against prague the white queen
was on the a5 square against dude
against dubois last season the white
queen was on the a5 square he got
checkmated both times i mean we're going
to see lightning strike again is there a
bishop slide yeah i was thinking that
can the bishop just move itself to the
castle let's just slide the bishop in we
saw magnus just kind of shake his head
there close his eyes and shake his head
i mean is this game over looks like it
is immediately are you winning you're
winning material here you're winning a
rook right yeah i mean an exchange at
least will we see a result any moment i
want to show this on the board but i
think we might see magnus carlsen just
throw in the towel and forget this game
because it's disastrous wow this is
incredible i just did not predict this
after everything has happened and after
everything we said i mean hands coming
out the black pieces playing this is
just what we want uh look at magnus
he knows he's he's and also he's he's
just been destroyed yeah by the hands
monster
so i mean anyone can lose a game magnus
can lose a game but not in this fashion
so one-sided the whole game ever since
the opening it's just been hand smoothly
out playing the world champion
incredible yeah incredible incredible
game actually so
yeah we should mention this bishop
cannot really be captured i mean maybe
it will be but if it is captured the
black rook will come down and take the
white rook on the d1 square
white's rooks are skewered they're
pinned
one of them is dropping to the black
bishop
and i mean material and you're facing a
scary attack
okay magnus just grabs a pawn there and
now the white rook will drop
yeah i mean it's not just the exchange
it's black still attacking
so if it was just the exchange you could
you can try to hold on but uh black's
attack continues and there's more pawns
that are going to drop
blacks rooks can come in the bishop can
come in
this it should be completely over now
and uh
yeah this this would be a good time for
the laptop to go down right
this is or the mouse to stop working or
something yeah we do have a result in
the arena
it's a win for levon aronian with the
black pieces against young christoph
duda also ali reza ruja and liam lei
have played a draw in their first game
but are we about also to see another win
with the black pieces in the arena hans
nima on the bar all the way over to his
side against magnus carlsen what a win
that would be
yeah and he's doing the right thing he's
pausing he's not being impatient and
just kind of playing moves because
that's when blunders happen um he has
calculated that he's completely winning
now we'll see a rook trade
and okay white's night retreating how
many times has it done this dance this
is the third time white's knight has
ended up on this square and okay it's
attacking the black rook as long as
neiman chooses a safe square for that
black rook he's going to win
look at the white pieces they're so sad
that white bishop the white knight he's
grabbed the pawn i mean why not i mean
there's other moves but you're right
white i mean
you can't not win this position now
surely you're right now scientists have
no chance to come back absolutely
nothing to be done
i mean just look at the poor bishop
that's sitting there on the h2 square
i mean it might as well be a pawn
this move is a killer you're threatening
to you know just take the knight and
check mate yeah you're right your anchor
and uh you're also not just the exchange
up you're you're pawn up now as well so
i mean any ending is just trivial
um
the king comes out
where's the killer blow there's a couple
here surely a couple of killer blows i
mean yeah you've got many many winning
moves there you can take a pawn with
your bish with the black bishop uh you
can even just capture the white knight
with the black rook i think that's just
a straightforward win this is the most
simple end
wow what can i say what's the result
phenomenal right
what a result yeah you said it david
incredible start to the day for hans
nieman the lowest rated player in the
tournament with the black pieces a win